hello everybody and welcome to my
Advanced flipping guide today I'm going
to show you the workflow that I go
through when I pick items all the way to
when I sell them uh I'll show you how to
flip expensive items how to flip cheap
items and how to pick the items
effectively so this is not a beginner
guide so if you don't have a basic
understanding of buying and selling a
RuneScape I would recommend just going
quickly looking up a beginner guide
first um I will be releasing one on my
channel eventually uh but obviously it's
not out yet and without further ado uh
let's get
started so to start off we're going to
have a look at some of the tools I use
uh to flip in RuneScape and really the
only one you need and the most important
one is RS budy exchange or at least
another website that shows the Grant
exchange's history um but this one I
find to be the easiest to use and has
the most kind of user friendly graphs um
so basically what we're going to do is
go to rs.com exchange uh you're going to
have a little interface so you're going
to look up the item we'll just do Bow
strings and you'll get some information
you'll get a couple graphs and there's
some info at the side so to start off
you have the graph which you can sort by
the month um the week and also the
quarter the quarter is about 3 or four
months so it's the longest period of
time that you can have a look at a month
is a bit shorter and weak um is the most
recent so basically each of these
different tabs has a different use based
on what item you're flipping how fast
you're going to be selling it we'll
start with the quarter so this is going
to be the general Trend that the month
are that the item has been going over
over the last couple months so you can
see the bow string basically has been
rising up until about July now it's kind
of slowly falling back down um this is
mainly useful for longer flips or if
you're just looking for the general
trend of the item so this has been
slowly going down it's not really
crashing down so if you go even lower
and go to the month you can see it's
still kind of on a slow downward curve
um but as far as flipping bow strings
this wouldn't be an issue you can see in
the week it's pretty pretty straight I
mean it does obviously go up a little
bit um but it's not fluctuating super
hard so you'd be able to flip 20,000 of
these very easily and you'd be able to
sell them before any of the prices would
change so next up you have this little
info tab which has the Buy price and the
sell price and just some other basic
information about the item what you're
mainly looking for is to buy and sell
price this isn't always accurate um but
it's gets you in the ballpark now this
is only really used for when you have
really expensive items you kind of just
need to figure out generally what the
price is at for items like bowering is
you might you're way better off just
checking it yourself by buying and
selling one in the grand exchange um but
mainly you're going to be using this for
more expensive
items the amount traded down here is
very useful it's going to show you
generally how quickly your items are
going to buy and sell so you can see the
bow string uh keep in mind that actually
this graph will change based on what tab
you have over here so you can see the
month and then the graph will change
totally uh so we'll go back to the
highest amount uh so you can see here
now this is when you have it on quarter
it's going to show you it every 3 days
the most use useful is just go to month
it'll show you every day how many are
sold um and bought so the bow string has
about 2 and half million sold every days
if you break that down per hour you keep
looking at a couple hundred thousand so
these would buy and sell very quickly um
if you go down to the week even shorter
you can kind of look by every 3 hours I
believe or something yeah every 3 hours
there's about 500,000 traded so this is
a very useful tool when you're looking
at the velocity of how many items are
being sold and bought if you're
wondering the reason why these are
different because you might be thinking
well shouldn't the buy amount bought and
sold be the same um but apparently what
I looked up is that because this is only
data pulled from the OS buddy website
anyone completing an offer in the
regular Run State client is not recorded
uh so the sales amount bought and sold
can kind of get skewed so that's kind of
a basic rundown of the RS Bud exchange
we'll be jumping back in this tool later
as well okay so quick flips uh this is
just going to be a quick rundown of my
entire thought process how I go through
and determine what item I'm going to
flip uh how I sell it everything that I
do from start to finish uh so first I
start off by basically just buying and
selling a bunch of different items and
then I'll take that information and move
on to the next step so what I'm going to
do next is so just say I take a an item
that's bow strings again you're going to
first figure out the margin um again you
to get the sell price take off the Buy
price it's going to be your Mar margin
but after that I'm going to do one more
uh quick calculation I'm going to take
my U Buy price and divide it by the
margin I just got and that's going to
give me a ratio and what this ratio is
is how much money I have to spend to
earn one GP back from the flip so that
way you can easily kind of just go
through a chart and just see how where
it falls in compared to other items
because it going to be kind of hard to
determine how good an item is when like
what's the difference between um an item
that costs 500 GP and has a 5 GP margin
the item that costs 50 GP and has a 1 GP
margin it's kind of hard to determine
just from the margin how good the item
is of course there are other factors
they have to take into account like how
many are sold every day and a couple
other things but mainly this is very
useful so basically after that I
determine uh if it's good based on the
ratio so here is how I kind of break it
down so it has a ratio of 10 or lower uh
which means you have to 10 H spend 10
gold or less get one that would be
extremely good um insane that would be
the best one um 10 to 20 would be very
good and 20 to 50 would be just kind of
good still above average um 50 to 100
would be kind of your average um if
you're spending more than 100 gold to
get one GP back that I would probably
skip it not always but it kind of
depends on the item if there's nothing
special about it i' probably skip it
okay so we have RS buddy Exchange open
here so after first kind of doing our
first calculation for the item uh we're
going to go here and just check a couple
extra things before we actually flip it
so we decided to do the ASO instead
let's get in
here uh so we're going to be looking for
is just the graph and the amount traded
uh so first let's look at the amount
traded so there's 4 million traded every
day so that's a that's loads that's tons
that's great uh next what we're looking
for is the historical value of the item
so if we go to weak is what you're going
to be looking for mainly for the quick
flips uh because it'll be the most some
data uh so it's around 190 and I'll tell
you the margin quickly we bought it for
$199 and sold it for 190 uh so that's
it's pretty safe decently um at worst
you'll be breaking even whereas if you
actually complete the flip quickly I
will be getting a 9 GP profit and yeah
we will quickly just look at the ratio
here so it looks like it's a 21 GP ratio
which falls into the uh good category or
very good I don't know one of them uh so
it's still a good item to to flip so
we'll go ahead and do that and uh lastly
you're going to want to look at the
buying limit so to do that basically I
usually go to the uh old school
RuneScape Wiki um it's not 100% accurate
but it is pretty decent so we'll go
ahead and look up the astral Rune uh
looks like there's a 10,000 quantity
limit and that again will reset after
four hours so every four hours you can
buy 10,000 of these so it looks like the
astral Rune will be a good item for us
to use uh so we'll go ahead and flip
that okay so now for slow flips I'll be
honest I have a bit less of experience
with this um but this is pretty much
what I've determined so far from doing
it essentially it's a lot of guesswork
so you're not really sure exactly what
the prices are going to be unless you
just kind of put in an offer and see if
it completes of course there's a couple
things he can do to kind of help you uh
which I'll explain to you now but
there's it's not as exact uh from my
understanding it's doing the quicker
flips uh but yeah first we'll go into
our bu again so we'll use that and we'll
pick a item we're going to do the check
the infinity
hat um so basically what you're looking
for more here is just the buy and sell
price which again is not totally
accurate but it'll get you into the
ballpark it's also good to look at the
amount traded but start with the uh the
info here so it looks like it has about
a 25k margin on it uh which is not not
too bad and I trade it every day looks
like there's about 100 so basically that
can determine that you would probably
buy one in about an hour maybe a little
bit less assuming you have the right
price uh another thing to take into
account when flipping more expensive
items is the buying limit because you
will be hitting the buying limit very
quickly assuming you have the cash to do
so but yeah we'll go ahead and quick
look the buying limit for the infinity
hat which I think I already have
open
Infinity hat so you can see here it's 10
uh so you can only get 10 of them but if
you got a 25k margin that would be
pretty decent 250k so essentially what
you're going to do is you're just going
to go into your client and you're just
going to put in approximately around the
sell price again you can vary it a bit
and uh just see if it buys wait half an
hour an hour or something if it doesn't
buy bump it up another bit and um when
you finally do buy one you can know that
that is what the price is you can go put
another N9 in afterwards for this
particular item so it's definitely a
little bit less exact but that is the
gist of FP slower items and just before
I end the video I just want to touch on
another quick thing uh which is kind of
something that doesn't fit into either
the slow or quick categories and it's
going to be something I'm just going to
call a transformative flip um this is
basically taking an item quickly Chang
it into something else and flipping that
um I still count that as flipping as
long as it's not like a super time
consuming process I'd still count that
as flipping we don't want to do too much
hard work now uh but you want to um you
still want to be able to change the item
good example of this are when you
combine Crystal Keys when you DeCamp
potions I've heard people um charging
glories doesn't really count uh cuz it
it does take quite a while to do um but
I've heard people taking weapon poison
off of items I've heard people splitting
up potions into individual files and
selling them like there's a bunch of
different options I'm going to touch on
two that actually work pretty well and
are consistent and that being the uh
combining of Crystal keys and the
flipping or so the um the decanting of
potions so to start off with the crystal
Keys what you're going to do is you're
going to basically you're going to buy
and sell a crystal key which you can see
I've done there as well as buy and sell
the loop half of the key and the tooth
half of the key so what you're going to
take now is the the full Crystal key
that you bought that's what you're going
to be selling the keys for after you
combine them you're going to take what
you uh sold the loop and tooth half of
the key for and subtract that off of the
um the um Crystal Key price and that
will give you the margin of the keys
generally you can get 1,000 per key that
you've combined um so if that's the case
go ahead and buy equal amounts of the
tooth and loop hals of the key wait for
them to buy just going to spam click
them together to make the keys and then
resell them it's very easy doesn't
really take that long to combine the
keys you do need a lot of money however
but beyond that you can make upwards of
500k 1 mil an hour just by com combining
these keys
and for the last method you will be
decanting potions it's very easy to do
basically all you have to do is buy and
sell a three dose version of any potion
I generally do super energy super
defense super strength potions work
really well and uh then you're going to
buy at least buy the four do version of
the potion um which will give you all
the information you need to determine
the margin so what you're going to do is
you're going to take the four dose
potion and times it by 7 five and that
will give you the price you'll be
selling to that so then you're going to
subtract uh the three do potion off of
that and that'll be your margin uh
generally you can get upwards of 200 300
GP on each potion depending on the
potion and it's very quick once you've
bought the items you just have to go
down to this guy um called Bob I believe
and he'll decant the potions for you
very easy and I made probably millions
and millions during this and that is it
uh thanks for watching my advaned
flipping guide if you guys have any
questions please leave a comment down
below if you want to see more guides
like this just hit that subscribe button
uh to stay tuned all right I'll see you
guys next time